with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see get up to
speed faster as a new developer with AI
and Google Cloud then stay tuned because
here's the
rewind the rate of change for developers
in cloud has been fast and in order to
make the most of your time and the
various platforms you need to know how
to use the ever evolving Tools in fact
stack Overflow surveyed its users 80% of
which chose online learning options
about their biggest challenge and it was
the initial stages of getting familiar
with the coding languages and for many
devs they'll be familiar with this
Challenge and also their own learning
cycle get started get productive get
results so how is Google helping to
support and improve this learning cycle
well well when getting started you have
a few options Google Cloud CLI which is
a command line tool that you can install
on your laptop perform Resource
Management authentication all from a CLI
and that will help you get these things
done faster and improve your base level
of productivity because you don't have
to context switch as much even after
only a few days of basic familiarity
with the
product Google Cloud SDK helps in a
similar way with libraries and tools for
interacting with Google Cloud products
and
services and then there's Cloud code
which is a set of IDE plugins for
popular idees that make it easier to
create deploy and integrate applications
by enabling you to pull in API samples
learn and write code with Google cloud
and when you're starting out and looking
to get productive we have several
options for you to use to help meet
those goals for example
sample applications that are
preconfigured demo apps with Cloud code
or Cloud API browser which helps you
easily enable apis and get samples right
from the IDE and AI tools with options
that enable you to ask questions get
coding assistance and more and for
faster development and faster results we
have templates available in Cloud code
open-source projects and even Bard where
you can easily open up and start
interacting with the code samples and
what if it only took you a few clicks
with jump starts launched at next based
on common developer actions with
pre-built solutions from Google Cloud
you don't need to spend Cycles
networking all the options together each
solution features a combination of
products that we've handpicked to save
you time and get you up and running
faster and with all those courses a bit
of guidance or some kind of package or
plan plan of action is definitely
supportive with our learning paths you
can navigate your professional
development with pre-selected courses
that are tailored to your specific needs
including Hands-On quick starts where
you're guided step by step through
setting things up right in the console
and we're adding more all the time like
getting started with Google Cloud which
is helpful whether you're starting fresh
or coming from a different provider or
getting started with generative a I
which has seven new courses to help you
skill up for what's next and to help you
show credibility and Proficiency in
these domains we've got various
certifications too so whether you're
just starting out moving from a
different solution or even looking to
refine your skills and demonstrate your
abilities with Google Cloud we've got
the tools learning paths and
certifications you need if you'd like to
see the full talk check out the link in
the description and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great next rewind content thanks
for
watching